choice choice has always been an
important part of building virtual
worlds
it started with words on a screen which
you choose to go east into the woods
ourselves towards the village these
text-based Dungeons & Dragons adventures
eventually received interfaces allowing
you to see these worlds with your own
eyes and as the years tick forward these
games evolved from crumbled pixels to
lively sprites and eventually into the
glorious 3d worlds we explore today but
like their 2d predecessors these worlds
were filled with choices quests
objectives that could be completed in
various ways with several solutions and
outcomes games where you created your
own stories as gamers we like making
choices of all shapes and sizes
we like to choose what car we get at
Mario Kart we like to pick our favorite
gun or build our own design choice is
what separates games from basically
every other type of media sure some
choices are superficial and many are
basic but some choices have the ability
to fundamentally change the way a game
plays and when games react to our
choices why that's just about the most
satisfying thing a game can do the
choice is easy in many games you know
thinking what car you want to wear to
build your city these are relatively
simple things mechanically but it's when
you start to involve choice and
narrative that experiences that games
really start to struggle the point
season 3 episode 13 choose your own
adventure
the problems with choice and narrative
games are varied aside from the
complexity of creating realistic human
conversations that react to your input
there's also the problem of content more
choices means more dialogue options
different scenes and more complex
writing and even then unlimited choice
doesn't really work when you're trying
to craft the story a game that limits
might just allow you to murder the
antagonist in the first scene one way to
fix this problem is to go down the road
of choose your own adventure books by
allowing predestined storylines that
split at specific moments binary
decisions that branch outward like a
tree where we all start at the same
point but end at what of several
conclusions based on our actions the
final results are games with multiple
endings for a while this type of
storytelling became quite popular David
Cage has experimented in this area quite
a lot heavy rain was a game with
multiple characters that could die or
fail or make decisions that would impact
the direction of the story and the
actions of the final climactic scene
beyond two souls did the same but these
games have to highlight the important
decision-making moments and in a game
we're making a wrong turn could murder a
beloved character in a game where the
stakes were so high
gamers wanted to be telegraphed these
decisions ahead of time this meant that
however complex the puppet strings you
could see them and ultimately it made
these worlds feel about as dynamic and
real as choose your own adventure books
where you play the part of a god
deciding the paths of characters rather
than a character in the world making
decisions themselves this was the
biggest fundamental problem with the
Walking Dead games to a series heralded
for its storytelling when these games
launched they had on-screen prompts that
would let you know when important
decisions were being made this was
designed to arm the player with the
knowledge that they are impacting the
world in subtle ways but what it
actually did by letting the players know
what was important was communicated a
player that all the other decisions
weren't important and that's another
thing gamers hate being asked to make
decisions that have no impact on the
world whatsoever one way around this is
having choices that matter more than
others this is certainly the case in
games like fallout in Skyrim choices in
the main quest impact the core storyline
splitting it off and changing variables
but side quests are on connect
I need to play with your choices over
there however splitting the importance
of these decisions is basically the same
problem the walking dead house so maybe
you shouldn't Telegraph what's important
to the player maybe they should just go
in blindly well that's what Mass Effect
2 tried to do and it wasn't until you
reach the suicide mission at the end of
the game that you realize that certain
character quests and ship upgrades were
important come by the time many players
did have the best characters in the game
of dive on them so many decided to
reload their safe game and go back to
complete these missions so as you can
see the world of player agency and
storytelling is a delicate balancing act
gamers want to be in control but they
don't want total control they want to be
able to make informed decisions but they
also want to leave space to be surprised
so how do you make a game that achieves
these opposite goals well it seems
there's a group of people in Poland who
have taken a pretty good swing at it The
Witcher 3 Wild Hunt is a game about
meeting people some people you have
lasting relationships with and some you
won't but these are all people you
interact with solve problems with work
for or work against the game has a core
plot that runs throughout and takes
place in a landscape full of side quests
to keep you occupied this is nothing new
in and of itself GTA Assassin's Creed
and are all games full of side
objectives but they're clearly laid out
as such by comparison taking a look at
the map in The Witcher 3 doesn't really
tell you anything about what you have
and haven't done and though it is a game
with main quests and side quests the
lines between these quests are so
blurred it's often hard to see the wood
from the trees sometimes quests
branching off of the main storyline go
on so far that they don't seem connected
to the main quests anymore sometimes
innocuous side quests of characters that
reappear in the main quest and remember
your actions the game continuously
purpose for the obfuscates how the
quests are connected it doesn't tell you
when things are important and it doesn't
punish you for not completing optional
quests or rather if it does you don't
ever realize it's a game full of tough
grey decisions this isn't good or bad
you know Paragon or renegade this is the
lesser of two evils
sometimes the stakes are high but
sometimes they're so low you might as
well have not been asked to make a
choice in the first place but there are
so many decisions to be made in the
witcher that you stopped
taking note of them unlike the walking
dead or heavy rain where every decision
you make is mentally catalogued and
thought off hours down the road in Wild
Hunt you lose sight of every decision
because of the sheer number and variety
of them there are so many puppet strings
that at a certain point you just kind of
stop looking at them and it's in that
complexity that decisions in The Witcher
3 feel legitimate because much like life
when we make decisions we don't suddenly
think about what branch of our life were
moving on to we make the decisions that
feel right we go with our gut life is as
much about those big decisions as it is
about those innocuous one that impact us
down the road Meredith choice in video
games have always felt like choose your
own adventure books but the beauty of
wild Hans is that it's a game where you
never fully understand how your
decisions are impacting the world you
can make mistakes and the world doesn't
end or you can make what you think is
the correct decision and then watch
somebody die that's the power to which
you're three and that's why the
decisions in this game feel real because
instead of going back and trying to fix
them they feel like they're yours if you
like you can accept and learn on the
regardless of the conclusion
you
[Music]